this candidate is once-in-a-lifetime I'd
be ashamed for the election to boil down
to the lesser of two evils California
has the largest Latino population in the
United States that means there's 6.9
million Latino voters eligible to vote
here today the Democratic race is tight
and it's down to the wire for Bernie
Sanders
we're in Boyle Heights a neighborhood in
East LA that's 95% Latino it's where
young supporters like Daniel Matta have
been campaigning hard for Bernie
literally going door to door why
specifically target Boyle Heights boy
Heights while I live here and also it's
highly populated it's a the second
largest and our district 34 with
Democrats so I really want all of them
to go out and vote for Bernie Daniel is
a 21 year old son of undocumented
Mexican immigrants he's studying
biomedical engineering and never voted
or cared for politics until he heard
Bernie Sanders speak now he's even
designed stickers and shirts for his
candidate waffles just like dude or
homie and local it says crazy
I came crazy homie the crazy people are
the only ones I guess stuff fun you know
the ones that are that that dream big
and actually try to change stuff despite
Clinton's national lead Daniel still has
high hopes he campaigns out of a
community art space that's become an
unofficial Bernie headquarters in the
neighborhood all I'm doing right now is
for my my cousin's my younger cousins I
wanted to go to college without having
to worry about the price I want all my
uncle's my aunts to have papers to be
able to go to the doctor for a checkup
so I'm fighting for all my family this
I'm doing this for them I really doing
it for myself because I really want them
to have the best possible feature and I
believe that to a Bernie Sanders
[Music]
five miles away Daniel Gonzales is
making vive Bernie signs at the print
shop he owns he's made around thirty
five hundred over the past several
months Wow
Daniel's parents were also undocumented
until recently he says Bernie is a
candidate who most resonates with his
beliefs and morals I asked him what he'd
do if Hillary wins the nomination so
Hillary Clinton I think needs to start
you know not apologizing but matter
being exacting so entitled to this
presidency if she's elected president we
will hold her feet to the fire
[Music]